Republicans are furious with a
Democratic senator for revealing
closed-door testimony from the Russia
investigation Senator Dianne Feinstein
released more than 300 pages of comments
from Glenn Simpson the co-founder of
fusion GPS to the Senate Judiciary
Committee back in August Simpson's firm
commissioned the now-famous dossier on
President Trump that contains
unsubstantiated evidence of his ties
with Russia Paula Reid has the testimony
that tries to support the claims made in
that report Paula good morning good
morning now Democrats say the testimony
shows the dossier was legitimate and it
actually mirrored what the FBI heard
from other sources in Simpsons testimony
he claims he had no reason to doubt the
reporting by Christopher Steele the
British intelligence agent who was the
author of the dossier a Simpson stated
Steele took the dossier to the FBI when
he became concerned that there was a
security issue about whether a
presidential candidate was being
blackmailed by Russia he went on to say
the FBI had reason to believe Steele
because they had other intelligence that
indicated the same thing including a
human source from inside the Trump
Organization now Republicans are calling
Feinstein's move confounding and they
suggest it could jeopardize future
testimony Paula
mr. Trump's lawyer Michael Kohn filed
the defamation lawsuit against BuzzFeed
news infusion GPS over this dossier what
does that mean well it's a risky move on
the one hand this plays well with this
ongoing conservative campaign to sow
doubts about the Russian investigation
and the dossier but on a lawsuit like
this it has a discovery phase and that
could require the President or mr. Cohen
to release personal information that
could be politically damaging mr. Cohen
has denied any connections to the
Kremlin and he's asking for a hundred
million dollars in damages Fallon gives
lawyers a hunting license thanks Paula